and large accent joins us on the program
Lamar how are you I'm good I'm doing
okay what's different this year as
opposed to last year for you you know
just everything you know my ability so
you know thanks faster on the field um
you know just let the game come to me
you know not trying to just take it um
you know just take it out a storm you
know just let it come to me I'll play my
game you know my knowledge has grown a
lot more from last year to this year
everything how do you practice calling
plays like did you ever do it by
yourself where you're you're you know
looking at yourself in a mirror you're
by yourself yeah yeah actually I did you
know I got a mirror um last year
actually my work here and I just caught
a place out on the long plays out you
know much as I can you know repeat
myself almost I'll say well wait so
you're you just want to see what you
look like when you're doing it no I'm
saying the play you know I'm saying play
over and over I'm looking at a piece of
paper with the players on it you know
the phrase run up um the word of the
play you know I'm just going over a
pedal in my head and you know out loud
but do you have neighbors do they wonder
what's going on in your your house if
you're calling plays in front of a
mirror to yourself where's where's the
Heisman Trophy right now it's with you
Oh mom sounds no oh my mom stays with oh
she does didn't so she cooks for you my
girl oh okay
does mom have a go-to meal on game day
before you know whatever you know come
to my nobody helped me out while I'm not
doing the fear who gave you the nickname
smiley face smiley face I remember is
that a real nickname
my research staff said that your
nickname growing up with smiley face how
often do you get to call your own plays
oh not know okay but when it comes to
running it feels like we always think
when we see a quarterback running that
it's rarely a designed run
how many design runs does coach Harbaugh
give you you don't give me the sign runs
you know it'd be our peels stuff like
that you know it's either option of give
um throw or run so you know it's really
up to the defense whatever they give us
take advantage of it did you watch the
game last night
I'm not dated really no I did it do you
like watching the NFL yes I do sometimes
[Music]
so what were you doing last night that
you didn't good for you if you can get
sleep I I saw that the first pitcher
threw out the Orioles game what kind of
baseball player were you below average I
wasn't you know I don't really put in
the power behind it you know it was just
a curiosity continue could you throw
hard could you throw a baseball hard I
feel I can but you had no interest
playing that growing up I did but you
know the coach well actually I did a
high school I really wanted to a high
school but the coach the baseball head
coach he was like nah he don't want me
to get hurt anything like that yeah does
your mom ever say did she ever worry
about your safety no see what she do you
know see the mother of course he's
concerned about my safety but you know
I'm playing ball you know it comes with
and also when you said I think it was
after the Dolphins game in week one you
said not bad for a running back who was
that who was that comment meant for well
a lot of people thought that you know
you're you're not gonna be able to play
that position I always wonder about that
when they say well I said
through in college so why don't you
think you've thrown the NFL but for some
reason people labeled you is just you
you could only run
they forgot you know it's like rg3 rg3
he faced the same criticism as you did
you know well before you did you ever
talk to them about that oh no I don't
you know I really don't but you know
this we just we just made the game so
different you know we were on the ball
you know it just you know gives people
who's and hours and stuff like that they
really don't care teach to the problem
but you know when when everyone was our
rg3 throw the ball he was you know it's
one wonderful you know accurate passer
you know he was 67% oh you know on what
percentages completions and stuff like
that so I don't know why they downplay
that much but you know it is what it is
gonna continue to us play ball would you
like to rush for a thousand yards this
year uh it no matter to me whatever
taste win all right that's what I'm all
about stats and stuff that's a good
answer but deep down if I ask you
privately you want to rush for a
thousand momma say the same thing
oh you would when you guys watch film
and you know you Juke somebody and you
know it's coming
what's that feeling like come on you
know you love it I don't know I'm trying
to score if anything who hits you the
hardest so far in your young career I
don't know I don't know you didn't have
no you didn't have one of those no
actually um I dunno soccer game I got
hit my arm my left sock or understanding
soccer faster and I got why I didn't get
knocked up but he just caught me real
good
how much did he know that he did it uh
he knew he knew it was like a horse kick
[Laughter]
what did you buy your mom um I bought
out of that truck oh yeah that was she
she always told me that was when I was
younger not too
the wunderbar she will get herself so
tell us my gift that's nice did you put
the bow on it no I did it I just pretty
much just drove up put up no twist to
the line I was like yo get your car do
what it was I like that
I wins last time coach Harbaugh yelled
at you talk to me you know huh well then
you're lucky that's pretty good yeah
it's been fun and continue to ball out
there you're doing great things there
and don't let anybody tell you can't be
a pocket passer all right that's a Lamar
Jackson
iseman Trophy winner for more Dan
Patrick show tune in the audience
channel 239 on DirecTV stream for free
on BR live or download the Dan Patrick
show app
[Music]